eu quero chamar sua atenção para o
conteúdo do café instantâneo aromatizado
como o café com leite ou cappucino de
mercado embora apareça inofensivo contém
uma série de aditivos ingredientes nada
saudáveis como cereais amido de caramelo
malte aromatizantes e até gordura
vegetal geralmente o açúcar figura como
o primeiro ingrediente nesse tipo de
produto o que indica que ele é o
componente mais presente por outro lado
felizmente a maioria dos cafés solúveis
puros no Brasil não contém esses
aditivos e açúcar um elemento que
realmente deve despertar sua atenção sua
preocupação é a acrilamida trata-se de
um componente químico que pode ser
prejudicial à saúde e que é formado
durante o processo de torrefação dos
grãos de café pessoal o café instantâneo
possui mais que o dobro de acrilamida em
relação ao café convencional a ingestão
frequente de Altos níveis de acrilamida
pode afetar o sistema nervoso e aumentar
o risco de câncer prefira seu café coado
ou feito na prensa francesa com pó de
grãos de torra média Clara